You could never know what it's like
Your blood like winter freezes just like ice
And there's a cold lonely light that shines
from you
You'll wind up like the wreck you hide behind
that mask you use
And did you think this fool could never win?
Well look at me, I'm coming back again
I got a taste of love in a simple way
And if you need to know while I'm still standing,
you just fade away
Don't you know I'm still standing better than
I ever did
Looking like a true survivor, feeling like
a little kid
I'm still standing after all this time
Picking up the pieces of my life without you
on my mind
I'm still standing (Yeah, yeah, yeah)
Once I never could have hoped to win
You're starting down the road leaving me again
The threats you made were meant to cut me
down
And if our love was just a circus, you'd be
a clown by now
You know I'm still standing better than I
ever did
Looking like a true survivor, feeling like
a little kid
I'm still standing after all this time
Picking up the pieces of my life without you
on my mind
I'm still standing (Yeah, yeah, yeah)
Don't you know that I'm still standing better
than I ever did
Looking like a true survivor, feeling like
a little kid
I'm still standing after all this time
Picking up the pieces of my life without you
on my mind
I'm still standing (Yeah, yeah, yeah)